Like a boss.
And I saw this thing called Ovarian
psychos and I was like, I want, I want,
I got it. Well, I gotta see what
this is about. It was about some, uh,
some women in east la, mainly Mexican,
who are sick of fucking being scared women
and they started their own group when
they ride around these
women's only, um, you know,
riding bicycles when there's like
a full moon or some shit, I dunno.
Ovarian cycles is a young woman of color,
a bicycle brigade. It's
a refuge for the runaway,
for the away
[inaudible]
the majority of us, if not all of us
have some kind of trauma in our life.
[inaudible]
I dunno.
So I was watching this stuff and of
course typical guys look googled you
women's, all league like such as
the ovarian cycle, right. As the only
right. I'm aware of where they see, no,
you're a 15 year old boy, you have
the wrong set of genitals go away.
Well, the fire guys all only bud. Right.
I hate when people act like
it's a level playing field.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
It's like they're having this thing
because it's not a level playing field.
One of the women in there was just like,
everything's kind of full
fucking men only. What's your,
it really is when you
really look at it. Okay,
I don't want him to fucking come off as
like a complete goddamn liberal here.
People would buy like messages on Facebook
about why is it okay for women to do
this and not for men and
guys do is for men.
All right, but you know,
it really is. It's just
okay.
It's there for the taking for
you. When you're a guy, you know,
not saying you're going to get it.
Nine out of 10 people still fail.
That's one thing that feminists
don't realize. You know,
when you listen to them talking about
what it's like to be a guy that had this
cartoonish idea of what it's like
to be a guy, you just show up. Oh,
and the classic one, the more you act
like a Dick, the more people respect you.
I love that one. If a woman of a woman
does it, she's considered a bitch.
If a guy does it, it's like,
have they ever done a survey?
Just ask the general public, Hey,
if you had your choice between working
for somebody nice or working for a
complete fucking asshole who treats
you like shit, which would you pick?
Um, anyway, so I'm watching
this documentary, check it out.
It's actually really a,
you only get bothered me
about the documentary is the
way they spelled psychos,
ovarian psychos. It's
like you're on cycles.
So why didn't you spell the first half?
Like cycle and the rest like psycho,
you know, little wordplay there.
Nothing. All right. Anyways,
so I watched it and it was interesting
and actually it's this one woman said in
it, you know, cause she'd been through
all this shit when she was, uh,
a little girl with their mother.
At first I thought I would try as
much as a kid could try. Right.
But I didn't have the words to say to say.
And so my mom was saying
that I was being silly.
That's my dad and that and that,
that I have to be, I have to,
I use my dad and how can
you not love your dad?
And so it was very confusing. And so,
and then she had a daughter, I believe
she was at least she had a kid,
she became a mom. And then
her mother said, well,
now do you at least understand me?
I bet you understand me a lot more.
And she said to her mother, no,
actually I've never understood you less.
That's my mom. And she comes into the
room and she's like, wow, you know,
now you know your mother now and now,
hopefully now you'll understand
me as a mom. Like she's up.
And I was like shocked because I
don't understand. And I just told her,
I was like,
I just went through 16 hours
of street pain like this labor.
And they phoned me up for this child
that I am now 100% responsible for her,
you know, or just like her,
her upbringing and for her to be
healthy and you don't say, and,
and I told her, I looked her in the eyes
and I told her, no, I mom, I friend,
I understand you even listen.
And I actually cringed when I, when I
saw that and I was just like, you know,
that's something if you feel
it, you don't say to your mom,
okay,
like what do you get out of
saying that to you mother?
All you're going to do is devastator
and make her feel like she completely
failed as a mom and it doesn't
get you any real estate.
That's something you say to your
friend. And now that I have a kid,
it's just like, I don't even understand
what the fuck my mother did to me.
Even more. [inaudible] you fucking clink
you wine coolers and then that's it.
You don't say it to your mom.
We're checking callers.
Do you know what? Can you please
go upstairs and get your brother?
Why do I always have to do it? Just
do it. Don't you give me that book,
man? That bitch got herself a nice
little dog. What did you just say?
You heard me? No. Say it
again. Ronnie say to my face,
which muddy? You Jealous
Young Daughters Ass, Huh?